this video is brought to you by
squarespace whether it's your new
profession or just a lifelong passion
start your journey to website glory with
squarespace check out their awesome all
in one platform through the link in the
description below
more on them in just a bit
in all of american history there have
only been two men who were both fathers
of a president and the president
themselves the former was founding
father john adams the second was george
h.w
bush a decorated navy pilot and former
head of the cia
bush was perhaps the most qualified man
to ever occupy the oval office
at the moment he was elected president
in 1988 he became the first vp to move
straight into the job without his
predecessor dying or resigning since
martin van buren in 1836 for
contemporary politics watchers it looked
like bush could become
a president almost as great as his old
boss
ronald reagan yet that's not what
happened despite approval ratings that
peaked at 90
percent bush senior was destined to be a
one-term president his name remembered
today more in connection with his son
than his own time in office even his
signature achievement defeating saddam
hussein and the gulf war was quickly
overshadowed by junior's 2003 invasion
of iraq
but is this really a fair assessment or
was there more to bush 41 than meets the
eye
if anyone could have seen the boy that
morning they would have been certain
he was about to die he was sat on a tiny
raft to drift in the pacific blood
flowed down his face from a nasty gash
red welts from jellyfish stings burned
his limbs
every few minutes the pale shaking boy
would vomit
bringing up yet more sea water his
crewmates were dead
killed when the guns brought his plane
down and now
they were coming for him too as the boy
weakly tried to paddle against the tide
he could sense them
the boats were getting nearer the boats
carrying the soldiers who torture him to
death
like they had the others it was a fight
for his very life one any independent
observer would have concluded that the
boy was destined to lose
but destiny had other ideas the pass
that led to george herbert walker bush
nearly dying that bright pacific morning
began two decades earlier
on june 12 1924 when he was born
into new england royalty and we mean
that almost literally his investment
banker father prescott sheldon bush
claimed he could trace his lineage all
the way back
to a sister of king henry viii in short
the family george became a part of was
the epitome
of the wealthy east coast elite that
meant an early life of privilege of
being educated at exclusive boarding
schools but this wasn't the kind of
brash elitism you might see today
the family was old-fashioned rich the
type for whom volunteering and charity
work were
as important as attending the country
club as an adult bush would live by the
motto that
there could be no definition of a
successful life that does not
include service to others still that
didn't mean he couldn't enjoy living in
the one percent
bush's first 17 years passed in a haze
of genteel dances and successes on the
sports field so much so that
he even considered becoming a
professional tennis coach but then
something happened that would change
not just his life but the lives of
everyone in america the bombing of pearl
harbor
the usa's 1941 entry into world war ii
caused an upswell of patriotism that
even the ultra wealthy weren't immune to
the day he turned 18 bush enlisted to
help fight the japanese he'd quickly
earn his wings becoming the navy's
youngest pilot
by now he was an athletic young man with
a sweetheart barbara pierce a
descendant of the 14th president who had
met at a country club dance
it was clear that if bush survived the
war he was going to come back and marry
her
sadly that was a pretty big if about a
quarter of all u.s fatalities in world
war ii were airmen with
a hundred thousand losing their lives in
the war's inferno george bush was
nearly among them on the 2nd of
september 1944 the future president was
on a bombing run
above chichijima when the japanese shot
him down
he bailed into the ocean cracking his
head on the plane's tail as he fell
it's here that we found him in our cold
open weak
and adrift and close to death while the
japanese tried to capture him
instead after hours at sea he was
finally rescued
by a u.s submarine of the nine men shot
down during the chichijima bombing run
bush was the only survivor
the other eights were captured tortured
to death and beheaded there's even
evidence that japanese officers
ate parts of their bodies although bush
wouldn't find out how close he came to
this gruesome fate for decades
he still had trouble figuring out why
why had he been the only one spared he
finally concluded
there's got to be some kind of destiny
and i was being spared
for something on earth
in the end george and barbara didn't
wait until the war's end to marry four
months after his near-death experience
bush returned home on leave and married
barbara in new york state
but although this was just a short break
he wouldn't be in the navy much longer
the war ended in summer 1945 in
september bush was discharged now in
possession of a distinguished flying
cross medal within days he'd have
slotted right back into his privileged
old life enrolling at
yale on a fast-track economics degree he
also pretty quickly became a family man
george and barbara's first son was born
on july the 6th 1946. they named him
george walker bush after his pop many
decades later bush jr would grow up to
be a president more impactful and
more controversial than george could
ever dream of but all of that
lay in the distant future for now bush
graduated from yale then
moved the family to texas where he
planned to strike it rich in the oil
industry it would be in houston that the
former pilot finally made his move into
politics
at the time texas was a mostly
democratic state that had nonetheless
turned red for eisenhower
perhaps sensing an opportunity bush
began working for the local branch of
the republican party
eventually becoming its chairman by 1964
he was popular enough among the
grassroots to
chance a run at the senate 12 years
earlier his dad prescott bush had
managed to win a seat as a gop senator
for connecticut and it seems likely that
bush was trying to match his old man
unfortunately he chose the wrong
election to start with
1964 was the year the lone star state's
own son lyndon b
johnson not only ran for president but
ran against a weak
republican opponent less than a year
after the assassination of jfk
the democrats absolutely crushed the
opposition in texas
bush might as well have just spent the
entire campaign on the golf course for
all the good it did him still bush was a
guy who learned from missed
opportunities
when he ran for the house two years
later he ran as a staunch moderate one
who highlighted his devotion to texas
this time it was enough on january 3rd
1967 george h.w bush entered congress
for the first time
it was the start of a political career
of wild ups and downs
while other presidents like lyndon
johnson hit the ground running the
moment they entered congress
bush managed to couple nearly every
success with an abysmal failure he won
two terms in the house for
example but again failed to enter the
senate in 1970.
on the other hand his reputation as a
moderate cause nixon to name him
the ambassador to the un on the other
hand and yes i'm aware we're up to
too many hands now bush would turn out
to be a crappy diplomat
achieving very little in those three
years but the epitome
of his seesaw luck came in 1973. that
year nixon made bush chairman
of the republican national committee a
powerful post
unfortunately he did so the same year
the watergate scandal really broke
which meant bush spent his time in the
rnc publicly defending a corrupt and
vindictive president
with dogged loyalty bush went to bat for
nixon right up until the smoking gun
tape was released
by the time he cut nixon off three days
before his resignation
bush had been so tired by the scandal
that he stepped down from his own
position
it looked like he might never work again
but scandals are funny things what seems
utterly explosive one year can be
completely forgotten by the next by the
end of the decade
bush wouldn't have just returned to the
corridors of power he'd be poised
to enter the white house now you might
not be poised for a run for president
but
you could run your own website thanks to
our friends at squarespace now more than
ever
people are getting creative with their
time they're reaching deep into their
savings accounts to start that new
business or launch that new blog to
share opinions with friends and
neighbors the world really is yours and
squarespace is the perfect web tool to
help you fashion it into whatever you
want it to be
it's the platform to use when you're
ready to get started on that next web
project that you've been thinking about
are you looking to get in and out quick
without thinking too much about what
your website's going to look like well
absolutely just use one of their
templates to make a website that's fresh
and for you or maybe you're more of a
hands-on person and you've got lots of
opinions and ideas about exactly what
your site should look like
squarespace gives you all the
customization options you could ever
want
with no updates no patches no technical
bs to worry about
once you're done setting up your website
tinkering with the design if you're so
inclined or
maybe playing around with the colors
there are so many extra features that
squarespace provides so that your
website can thrive email campaigns
patronage portals social integrations
member only areas analytics commercial
options
24 7 customer support there's a whole
lot of stuff in there
it's all in one place so when you're
ready to get started on that next
project of yours big or small if it
involves a website it's got to be with
squarespace right now you can go to
squarespace.com for a free trial and
when you're ready to launch go to
squarespace.com
forward slash biographics to save 10 of
your first purchase of a website or a
domain
and let's get back to washington
[Music]
the immediate aftermath of nixon's fall
saw gerald ford quietly shunt bush off
to beijing as envoy to china
it was the perfect place for bush to
keep his head low do some cycling and
try to shake off the stench of tricky
dick
finally after a year and a half in the
wilderness bush was at last asked to
come back
as the director of the cia although bush
held the post less than a year before
being forced out after jimmy carter won
the 1976 election
his name still looms large in the
agency's history the cia headquarters
today
is even named after him but for our
story it's the connections he made while
director
that's really interesting it was while
at the cia that bush first came into
contact with a shady panamanian
operative
known as manuel noriega spoiler alert
you're going to be hearing that name
again
after carter dropped him from the cia
bush returned to houston to lay the
ground for
what he felt would be a successful bid
for the presidency but we'll never know
whether the moderate paternalistic bush
could have beaten carter in 1980 because
1980 was the year
a certain governor from california also
decided he wanted the republican
nomination
the moment ronald reagan announced his
candidacy george bush was doomed
although he ran a good campaign
memorably calling reagan's policy
proposals
voodoo economics thus becoming likely
the only president ever quoted in a
radiohead song
he just didn't stand a chance reagan
crushed
everyone in his path for bush it looked
like the only thing to do was head back
to houston and
stew for four years but then something
unexpected happened
regan in need of someone who could win
over his party's moderate wing
asked bush to be his vp bush was as
surprised as anyone to get the tickets
but
he did a good job tirelessly traversing
the country drumming up support that
turned out to be totally unnecessary on
november 4th 1980 the reagan bush ticket
won
in a landslide when bush was sworn in
the following january it was as
vp of an america that was about to
change forever but while bush would be a
part of reagan's transformative white
house he'd never actually be a part of
it
reagan's team never forgave bush for
that voodoo economics jibe
nor could they forgive his costed
upbringing and patrician style
bush might have had a front row seat for
the reagan revolution but it'd only ever
be a spectator one good for sending to
meet foreign heads of state but
kept firmly away from the levers of
power still being out of the loop
sometimes
had its advantages and if you've not
heard of iran contra just know
it was the miller investigation of its
day and it was a scandal that dragged
on and on until it was seemingly all
anyone could talk about
erupting in reagan's second term the
scandal involved white house staff as
illegally selling arms to iran and then
using the prophets to also illegally
fund right-wing contra rebels in
nicaragua
and no two illegal things do not make a
legal thing when the scandal broke a
special prosecutor was assigned
eventually 11 people close to the white
house would be convicted for their roles
in it but not george h.w bush
just by rumors that the deal had only
been possible thanks to his cia
connections
bush insisted that he'd been out of the
loop and knew nothing a
not implausible scenario given his
unpopularity with reagan's team
it was only much later that a diary
entry of his was unearthed reading
i'm one of the few people that know
fully the details of iran contra
it is not a subject we can talk about
regardless bush survived the scandal to
finish his second term as reagan's vp
but he wouldn't be content to leave
office alongside his old boss
back in 1984 the second reagan bush
ticket had won one of the greatest
landslides in u.s history comparable to
fdr's victory in 1936
who was to say that leaving bush on the
ticket now as the headline act
wouldn't result in another republican
win although no vp had gone straight to
being elected president since martin van
buren in 1836
bush was certain that he could pull it
off
the only reason the 1988 election isn't
commonly remembered as a landslide
is because it paled beside reagan's two
knockout wins
but make no mistake bush won a thumping
victory taking 40 states and over 53
percent of the popular vote
unfortunately one reason he won so hard
was because he made an infamous promise
and all together now read my lips no
new taxes before long that quote would
come back to haunt bush like a
badly costumed scooby-doo villain
haunting an abandoned arcade
still bush entered the white house with
a solid mandate even if democratic
control of congress meant
his agenda would be constantly
frustrated which may be why there's
little to say about his domestic
policies despite talking at his
inauguration
about the problems of homelessness and
drugs bush's term
is best seen through the lens of foreign
policy the reason
the moment he entered the oval office
the world went absolutely nuts
the first major flare-up came in april
of 1989 as protests broke out in china
with up to a million
students flooding beijing's tiananmen
square to demand change
on the 4th of june the ccp called in the
military who dispersed the crowd
dispersed here meaning they murdered
hundreds of people
as the world condemned china congress
demanded action but bush believing a
strong relationship with beijing was
essential to american prosperity
only imposed limited sanctions the weak
response was seen as characteristic of
the overly cautious president but
there'd be nothing overly cautious
about his response to the next
international crisis since 1983 bush's
old cia buddy manuel noriega had ruled
panama
as an effective dictator with a sideline
in drug trafficking
initially the u.s tolerated him because
he had anti-communist credentials but by
1989 noriega was in business with the
sandinistas leading to the cia cutting
him loose when noriega annulled panama's
election in spring that year
they began actively plotting his
overthrow then panamanian soldiers
killed an off-duty u.s servicemen on
december 16th
and all hell broke loose bush authorized
operation just cause on december 17th
three days later the largest u.s troop
deployment since vietnam
invaded panama in the fighting somewhere
between 500 and 1000 panamanians lost
their lives mostly civilians
against just 26 americans noriega fled
into the vatican embassy where u.s
forces blasted loud music and
flashed bright lights at the windows
until the former dictator surrendered
on january the 3rd 1990 while the
invasion of panama was seen as a victory
in the u.s it was globally condemned
in panama they're still uncovering mass
graves containing civilians killed in
the battle
but before noriega was even captured
bush's attention was being forced
elsewhere on november 9 1989 the berlin
wall came down the most visible sign of
communism's collapse across
eastern europe mindful of antagonizing
the soviets bush chose to play the event
in the most muted way possible
merely telling a reporter i'm very
pleased at the time
this was seen as yet more evidence that
bush had a spine as
limp as a creepy handshake but today
most agree that he played things
well rather than gloat and risk a
communist backlash bush was content to
stand back and watch the whole edifice
come tumbling down with
just a quiet smile when he did play a
part it was often an
unglamorous but essential one it was
bush for example who's
credited with making german
reunification a reality in the face of
hostility from u.s allies like britain
not that his role
in the end of european communism was
always successful in 1991 bush tried to
stop the ussr's republics from
becoming new countries culminating in a
speech he gave in kiev calling the
ukrainian desire for independence
suicidal nationalism it was such a
tone-deaf
wimpy comment that it's gone down in
history as the
chicken kiev speech by and large though
bush handled the soviet collapse well
signing a non-aggression pact with
gorbachev in november 1990 that
effectively ended the cold war yet even
this wouldn't be remembered
as his signature foreign policy
achievement for that
we'll have to look to a nation that has
spent decades as a thorn in the side of
american politics
you guessed it it's time for us to talk
about iraq
unlike the mess that was the 2003
invasion there was a very clear
justifiable reason behind the first gulf
war on the 2nd of august 1990 saddam
hussein attacked the tiny oil-rich
nation of kuwait
in the face of superior iraqi forces the
army disintegrated
half a million people including the
royal family were forced to flee to
saudi arabia
and so began the most significant
challenge of bush's entire presidency
the first thing to do was to stop saddam
from rolling his tanks
straight in on saudi arabia and annexing
their oil fields
by august 7 bush had signed an order to
launch operation desert shield a
massive buildup of force nominally to
protect the saudis but already bush was
planning the next step
as u.s forces raced to the gulf bush
began aggressive diplomacy
to try and build a coalition force for
liberating kuwait
unlike his son in 2003 he did this with
the support of the united nations
before the year was out desert shield
had the support of countries from across
europe
america and the arab world bush even
managed to secure an agreement from
israel not to join the fighting
no matter what this was a clever move
bush knew that having israel attack iraq
would shatter his coalition
sending the arab states running and
turning the entire operation into a
gigantic mess
clearly saddam knew this too when the
fighting began he'd fire scud missiles
into israel killing civilians and
deliberately trying to provoke a
response
but bush's agreement with israel would
hold and saddam's last chance to divide
his enemies
would evaporate as the clock ticked
nearer to the un-imposed deadline for
iraqi
withdrawal from kuwait bush sought
approval from congress to fight a war
on january 12 1991 they narrowly voted
in favor
despite this there was concern that the
fighting would kill tens of thousands of
americans that saddam would unleash
chemical or biological weapons on the
invaders
instead it was one of the most one-sided
wars imaginable
the us-led coalition began airstrikes
against iraqi targets on january the
16th
as saddam lost control of the skies his
forces became sitting ducks on february
the 24th operation desert storm troops
entered kuwait
by february 28th it was over as iraqi
troops retreated leaving burning oil
fields in their wake
bush ordered a ceasefire by this time at
least 25 000 iraqi troops had died
compared to less than 250 coalition
soldiers
nowadays bush's decisive actions
liberating kuwait are seen
as his crowning achievement recently
he's also gained a lot of respect for
refusing to continue the war until
saddam was deposed
guessing rightly that it would lead to
the us getting bogged down in the middle
east
but this rosy view conveniently forgets
the gulf war's aftermath
on march the 2nd bush made a televised
speech hinting that the u.s would
support any homegrown attempt by iraqis
to remove saddam from power accordingly
dual revolutions erupted in the kurdish
north and the shia south
instead of u.s support though the
revolutionaries got saddam's helicopter
gunships
gunships the coalition forces authorized
saddam to fly
a hundred and eighty thousand civilians
are thought to have died in the
resulting massacre
not once did president bush ever dream
of intervening
in the aftermath of the gulf war it
looked like bush might be on course for
a second term
with just a year and a half till the
election his approval ratings were
around 90 percent
it also had a couple of domestic wins
passing the americans with disabilities
act outlawing employment discrimination
against the disabled and ushering
through the clean air act
sure there were occasional goofs like
that time he passed out and vomited on
the japanese prime minister
but it wasn't career-ending stuff no it
would be a budget act
and a recession that did that let's
start with the budget
in 1990 bush and the democrat-controlled
congress worked together
to pass the omnibus budget
reconciliation act desperate to get the
deficit down congress demanded tax hikes
which bush reluctantly signed on to
at the time it must have seemed like the
president could ride out the storm that
no matter
how annoyed his right wing got that
stick with him
over any democrat at the next election i
mean it wasn't like a common sense
populist was about to launch a massively
successful third party candidacy
disillusioned voters could turn to or
anything like that right still it's
possible bush could have survived
breaking his no new tax's pledge
had it not been for the recession
although it was technically over by 1992
the early 90s recession resulted in
unemployment that was still rising as
the election approached combined with
the tax hikes it created a perfect storm
of discontent among both america's haves
and have-nots it was into this storm
that george bush's executioner strode
william jefferson clinton was an
arkansas governor with an available
charm and a knack for appealing to blue
collar voters
who ran a campaign focused on the
faltering economy ross perot on the
other hand was
a brash populist running as an
independent and advocating for sweeping
change
combined they ate away at bush's support
from the left
and the right until his entire platform
came tumbling down on november 3rd 1992
the hammer finally fell
bush pulled in an atrocious 37.4 percent
of the vote
way less than even jimmy carter had
managed in 1980
not that clinton did much better though
although he dominated the electoral
college clinton picked up a mere 43
percent of all votes cast
the rest went to ross perot for the rest
of his life bush would privately blame a
combination of perot and
media bias for losing him a second term
when he left the oval office in january
1993 bush became one of only three
presidents since world war
ii not to win re-election although he's
since been joined by another
it was still a very lonely club one of
his last acts before stepping down was
to pardon everyone involved in iran
contra
a hugely controversial decision that
pissed a lot of people off
that done his single term over bush
returned to houston and quietly retired
from politics
unlike most ex-presidents he didn't do
any speaking tours didn't try to stay
politically active beyond the odd
charity fundraiser for disaster relief
even when his son became president in
2000 bush did little beyond note
that he was very proud of his boy george
h.w bush finally passed away on november
30 2018 just months after his beloved
barbara died
he was 94. today the 41st president's
tenure is probably remembered as
little more than a gap fill a breather
before the clinton years
a reagan tribute act without the great
man himself
while fans will point to his foreign
policy achievements it's worth
remembering
that even these come with qualifications
as the dead in panama
and iraq would attest so what then is
left to say
about the 41st president well he was
undeniably a decent person
a true gentleman who believed in charity
and supporting others
perhaps more remarkable from a modern
perspective though is that bush is the
last president
that both sides have considered
legitimate think of the 90s republicans
who claimed clinton was a murderer
who perot swung the election or the 2000
democrats who insisted fox news had
rigged florida for bush junior consider
the bertha movement obama fate the
accusations of russian meddling under
trump the
stop the steel campaign that physically
tried to stop biden's win from being
certified
since george h.w bush departed office in
american politics has become much more
poisonous much
more polarized the idea that
conservatives and liberals alike could
agree a president legitimately won his
election
seems like a bit of a depressing fairy
tale now
in the end perhaps that's the most
interesting thing about the bush
presidency seen today
how it represented a different time one
in which a decent man could try to do
his best as leader
and have both sides respect him for it
so i really hope you found that video
interesting if you did please do hit
that thumbs up button below don't forget
to subscribe and as always
thank you for watching